[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I like it I like it yeah all right
all right happy Tuesday everybody after
No Interruption the Dems lean into
corruption it's Tuesday so you know what
that
[Music]
means insane amounts of Swiss bank
accounts are overflowing cheat stealing
line to one bat tonight did you not
notice we have no qualms if you grease
our palms just as the podus financial
crimes can be fun sometimes as Hunter
showed us if you like cigars and bar
join the DNC
it's the place to be when you are the
face of
[Music]
[Applause]
corruption yeah if you remember that
song you probably own an acorn
stairlift let's first discuss the
Clinton Global initiative not to be
confused with Bill Clinton's oral
initiative the organization announced
the CGI Ukraine Action Network allegedly
to help rebuild that war torn country
and provide humanitarian Aid and like
most CGI it seems convincing until you
take a closer look here's how it works
the Dems send Ukraine a bunch of money
your money by the way to blow stuff up
and then the Dem send a bunch of bunch
more of your money to fix the stuff that
just got blown up and of course they get
a taste of that cash what a great system
right rebuild destroy rebuild build and
the Dems get paid both ways it's the old
Mafia trick bust a bunch of storefront
windows and then open a window repair
shop so now the clintons have set their
greedy fingers on Ukraine I'll bet bill
is in charge of the women's
prisons well he does have experience
sneaking cigars into small
spaces now just don't ask Hillary why
the Russian reset didn't work or that a
decade ago Obama told us to forget about
Russia back then the biggest challenge
was freeing women from Mitt Romney's
binders remember when Obama said the
1980s are calling to ask for their
foreign policy back he's about as good
at predictions as he is at
[Applause]
Hoops well the 80s did call Barack just
to say they're glad you stopped eating
dogs
[Laughter]
people forget that clearly our audience
did he ate a dog look it up but now that
there's money to be made the Russians
are suddenly back however one must ask
where was the Clinton Global initiative
during the Trump years Hillary tried to
convince everybody there was Russian
collusion but her CGI group lay dormant
like her gym membership for that entire
four years no wonder they hated Trump
the gravy train dried up like a stain on
an inter turns
dress now that Trump's out of office
Hillary is back in a big way and she's
making a killing okay bad choice of
words on my part but it's weird how that
works right Putin waited till a Democrat
was in the White House to invade Ukraine
and now the cash is Flowing to the Dems
but the clintons aren't the only ones
who've got who figured out how to profit
from other people's Misfortune ibram X
kendi the X stands for extra racist is
now responding after his Center for
so-called anti-racist research at Boston
U laid off half of the staff blowing
through 30 million bucks while only
releasing two research papers in two
years and one of them was just 500 pages
of the word
honky fact is Kendy formerly known as Mr
Henry Rogers doesn't want you to be his
neighbor unless you're a guilty
Corporation with cash to burn so where
did all that money go what does be have
to show for it couldn't that money pay
student loans for art history majors so
they don't harass me for tips at
Starbucks and how is it anti-racist to
BU a bunch of suckers out of their dough
only a school dumb enough to accept AOC
as a student would fall for that crap
but kendi Rogers has responded to the
controversy quote there will always be
people who critique the job someone else
is doing well yeah that's your literal
job description Bozo you're the Rotten
Tomatoes of race according to con artist
like ibram X kendi racism means any
criticism of ibram X kendi including
asking why he was handed $30 million to
squander kendi got his big payday and
you all can just fend for yourselves the
way this guy operates would make Al
Sharpton
blush I'm sorry but fat Sharpton will
always be my favorite
Sharpton there's so much there to hug if
all that isn't cartoonishly corrupt
enough for you how about Bob Menendez
the feds found an Untold fortune in gold
bars stashed away at his house who the
hell does this guy think he is William
[Laughter]
Dain Menendez also allegedly hid tons of
cash in his monogrammed
windbreakers funny usually when I hear
Democrat and windbreaker I think Eric
swell is uncontradicted that the
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the ukrainians to help him cheat an
election
it's an oldie but a
smelly now menendez's job was chairman
of the Foreign Relations Committee you
know which is a lot like Tony Soprano
working in Waste Management it's just a
cover to get bribes from foreign powers
because they always need something in
return say didn't Joe Biden have that
job too hard to believe there's someone
dumber than Hunter when it comes to
hiding bribes even crack boy didn't say
hey just give it to me in gold in Pieces
Of Eight like a pirate it's the second
time in a decade that Menendez has
gotten busted for corruption and he'll
probably get away with it again because
Dems do look after their own when you're
a Democrat corruption is just a fact of
life make a big speech about rebuilding
Ukraine or stopping racism or whatever
and then line your own pockets and your
dads or your sons the people you claim
to be helping may or may not benefit at
all but you sure do and Corruption comes
in all colors white black brown whatever
but the only color they really car care
about is green
or in the case of the Biden white but
worst of all this money is mostly your
money which they see as their money they
use political power for financial gain
and as long as their politics Lurch left
nothing can stop them it makes you
wonder if you chose the wrong political
side or should you really actually work
an honest job for a living one thing's
for sure though unlike the big guy no
one's putting aside 10% for us
perod let's welcome tonight's guest he's
proof that playing soccer causes head
trauma host of one nation in Fox and
Friends Brian
killme she's as vivacious as she is
loquacious host of the fox True Crime
podcast Emily
capano as a resident of La her favorite
hobby is running for her life Fox
Business correspondent Kelly o' Grady
and finally people are surprised that
someone this attractive is also funny
comedian Joe
Mackey Brian you know the clintons love
money as much as you love the
Limelight I really don't have anything
after that you want me to go yeah I
would Ukraine needs to be rebuilt no
doubt about it eventually but I'd feel
better if Frank Siller was doing for
tunnel of towers they were I know the
money would get there since when has she
ever produced money for Charities or an
organization that actually did anything
give give her power and influence I
couldn't believe she's teaming with the
Ambassador for Ukraine there's got to be
a better team disappointed number one
number two is I actually think uh
Ukraine the Russian invasion of Ukraine
is Criminal and you need to fight back
but I also have trouble sleeping because
I'm on the same side as Shawn Penn and
Hillary Clinton so I definitely need to
see that therapy for some of the maybe
the therapist that goes to your office
every day maybe they could send her down
it is indeed strange bed fellows right
and it's excusing all sorts of behavior
like for example lionizing a Nazi in
Canada Brian oh you talking about Justin
trau yes right no he's not a Nazi right
maybe he honored by mistake a Nazi it
happens you think you have a war hero
and turns up being a Nazi criminal it's
happened to all of us once in a while I
like to the man of the year I mean the
most evil man ever walked the plan I'm
sorry I picked up the wrong trophy yes
yes yes I get it you hire a gardener it
turns out he's a Nazi but you bring him
to Parliament that's a big deal so Emily
isn't this why they didn't want Trump
back in office and they're fighting so
hard because if Trump if Trump doesn't
win or if Trump wins there goes the G
gravy train again absolutely and keep in
mind that this is right after we learned
that we left behind upwards of $83
billion of assets in Afghanistan that's
our money right thanks to Adam angki we
know $175 Million worth of drones alone
we left more planes and airow there left
behind in Afghanistan than other NATO
Nations have on their own and now to
your point tax money taxpayer dollars is
now going to Ukraine so the Dory memory
that taxpayers are subjected to means
that we're supposed to forget about
about the debauchery and we're supposed
to forget about the multi-millions and
billions that we've already spent and
invested because of their failed foreign
policy to your point they're trying to
Ram it in no thanks to as well as we
were talking about earlier the AG of New
York's continual prosecution of the
Trump Foundation like their charity can
do no wrong right but the Trump
Foundation is serially the subject of
criminal and civil investigations um can
I make one quick point about the kendi
thing too sure just that just a point
she just interrupted herself to yes I
was politely asking for permission so
his quote was that women and people of
color he says are held to unfair
standards when they start he said I just
I'm asking for a fair shet can't leaders
of new organizations be given time to
develop time to make mistakes no man the
whole point is if you blow through 30
million in two years yes you're going to
get ax the whole point is anyone
regardless of color if they squander and
suck then yes they're going to be asked
out I guess except for Bill Clinton
there you go he's the only
exception everyone's lost 30 million
once kellyo Grady good to see you Kelly
Grady good to be here I feel like I need
to find a Guinness when I'm talking to
you welcome to the show after 5:00 right
yeah I know 5:00 somewhere so let me ask
you this so you see this uh you see
Menendez says the attacks on him are
racist Candi says it's attacks on racist
it's kind of unfair to the clintons
because they can't say
that I'm sure they would find a way if
they could right or sexist right if if
Hillary's jumping in you know I I just
see this and I get so frustrated because
I I agree with you Brian right you know
we do need to rebuild Ukraine but why
aren't we putting some of that money
towards the chaos that's in our own
backyard right you said I'm running for
my life out in Los Angeles I can affirm
that that is correct I have a French
Bulldog as well his name is Biggie she
get guest together yeah does he fart
like a just every single night snores in
my ear it's a miracle I'm awake yeah but
I'm I'm walking around trying to make
sure that this dog doesn't get stolen we
have homeless encampments everywhere why
can't we put some of that money Tor
wordss that instead of you know more and
more money to Ukraine oh wait we would
have to be reminded that it's liberal
policies that created that we don't want
to highlight that exactly so we care
more about a border across the globe
than our very own border Brian so put
that in your pip you could do two things
you know that right there's two separate
budget I can so no you can't let's go to
Joe Mackey the sexiest man
alive Joe you're a
you're a big Clinton fan you've been a
Hu you've been a huge follower of
Hillary since day one this must really
disgust you I don't know where you did
your research but I have to check my
Wikipedia page again but I'll tell you
what Greg you mentioned the mafia in the
monologue and to me it is like the mafia
uh it's you have to pay for protection
because we all know crime goes on we all
know that there's a lot of Republicans
and Democrats uh that somehow go into
office poor and come out rich and they
get these like speaking agreements for
more money than you get paid for a Joe
Macky standup show you know it's just it
doesn't make any Financial sense to
anybody really uh but the the problem is
you just have to take the bribe on the
right side you know that's like a like
Menendez went against Obama with uh Cuba
he went against Biden with the Iran and
he's getting investigated but Hillary
Clinton's having people take hammers to
servers nothing happens that's why you
just never see people like bribe on the
wrong side like no one bribes the cops
to do good yes has anybody tried to
bribe you to tell a certain joke uh no
they usually uh they they call them out
but when they know the joke it's not
funny because they know the
answer that's such a good point you know
the thing is if you did any of this
behavior in the private sector you would
go to prison the well uh the black lives
matter thing is the most underreported
underfocus thing I cannot believe how
much money is in how much money is gone
and no one paid the price for it and
everyone's afraid to say hey uh we put
in 10 20 $30 million and there's
absolutely nobody running the
organization nobody's gotten better no
one's gotten educated that story that
you gave me to read and comprehend and I
do do my homework yeah it had the the
$30 million they were supposed to one of
these groups supposed to give a grant to
a high school group to go to Africa to
learn more and all of a sudden they go
the money's gone sorry and the kids
after a while just disbanded their
organization was going to go and
everyone's out money and no one gets
prosecuted it's incredible you have to
admit though that's a terrible trip for
spring break that's true well it's a
long drive it's a long it's a really
long drive hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else